pour rester dans la politique aux
dernières élections
tu as voté la longue veste heures la
résidence j'étais embêté alors je ne
veux pas qu'il dispute je voudrais
adresser un message à tous les durées
continuera je ne me retrouve plus alors
j'étais obligé avec les petits bulletins
de fer amtrak g comme ça j'avais rien
dans leur enveloppe je ne sais pas de
qui tu sais pas ah non j'ai fait ça
comme ça j'ai trois pour toi c'est les
mêmes pour moi l'écologie doit être une
grande panique comme le cinéma en fait
beau dit moi le sommet de la terre à rio
la ds qu'on nous rabat les oreilles en
ce moment tu vois que ça va changer
quelque chose
pas tout de suite non mais c'est un bon
départ c'est qu'en nouvelle zélande il
commence déjà à pas empêché les enfants
des écoles de sortir à certaines heures
se protéger du soleil etc
ça commence à le singe est bientôt au
canada tout le pays près du pôle
non mais ça nos enfants ni comprend pas
des tirs au soleil avec les bulles là
oui c'est ça sa peau c'est la fin du
monde c'est pas la fin du monde on est
une espèce prend différentes donc il va
en rester un petit paquet pensera bien
content
concrètement tu fais quoi toi pour
l'écologie quantité dans le bordelais
par exemple qu'est ce que tu as fait
pour les coacher en plus de ben ouais
à quand j'étais à bordeaux après j'avais
mieux précis rythme pas de savoir alors
j'avais les deux poubelles
j'avais même les trente poubelles qu'est
ce qu'il y avait dans ses poubelles à
l'ariana viennent avec les plastiques
enfin tout ce qui n'est pas
biodégradable y en avait une avec le
bois le papier ça et dans la cheminée
il y en avait une avec les déchets
alimentaires alors ce qu'ils étaient il
ya le chien du voisin avait absorbé une
partie et l'aurait jeté à pourrir dans
un petit en mélangeant avec des buttes
de derb et tout ça pour hyper pointu
mais dans le jardin a fait quoi d'autre
pour l'écologie pour l'environnement bon
le bordeaux il voulait faire passer à
travers la forêt de léojac qui est la
plus belle forêt du sac et le plus joli
coin le peut dudu du sauternais tu vois
qu'un embarras vissac des vieux village
et où il voulait te tailler là dedans je
sais pas quoi 30 km de large et en avant
marche pour les exporter de
l'électricité à l'espagne mais cette
somme n'est qu'un fonctionnaire à
toulouse avec la règle et le papier
c'est pas méchant petit place à fabien
dunlop
tu vois la prônait talent et de
l'expliquer que non c'est vachement joli
ici on a dit pourquoi vous passez pas à
côté de l'autoroute c'est déjà tout
gâcher donc si tu es il ya bien la place
ça va être formidable à côté de
l'autoroute
ils nous ont répondu jean vous rendez
compte on va pas détruire le paysage de
l'autoroute ou alors la tourterelle et
c'est à dire que les tourterelles moi
j'ai jamais été contre la chasse je suis
trouve que la chasse c'est très bien
c'est un beau sport comme c'est bien
pratique et sur un gibier à l'automne
pourquoi parce que le gibier s'est
reproduit donc il est plus nombreux
quand c'est à gibier migrateur c'est
avant la migration idée repose et de son
été il est gras on peut le manger
bah oui ça sert à ça quand même hein
c'est pas la peine d'aller toucher pour
ça je déteste les chasseurs qui tire à
la mitrailleuse qui jettent ensuite fini
vraiment dégueulasse mais si c'est pour
manger c'est parfait la tourterelle ça
ne se mange pas elle est toute maigre
quand elle arrive c'est le printemps
elle n'a pas encore fait ses bébés
chacun suit une femelle tutu 4 bet
elle est un peu on va disposer au moins
une espèce menacée pour toutes ces
raisons là font que je suis évidemment
contre la chaîne cela tourne toi le kit
une chatte barbare et qui insulte à la
chasse en fin de compte y retourner
dix ans avec sophie marceau et bougrain
dubourg fait si j'avais dix-sept années
que j'y retournerais tu je n'étais pas
là et alors oui j'aimerais bien
retourner mais bon mais en même temps
sauf qu'il faut pas non plus c'est
vraiment là petit cache la forêt ça
parce que premièrement faut savoir qu'il
ya 90 % toutes espèces confondues
90% des oiseaux d'europe qui ont disparu
qui sont mort tu vois il n'en reste plus
que 10 % et c'est pas à cause des
chasseurs sa pause de la disparition du
biotope autrement dit les bétonneurs la
pollution les insecticides la
disparition des forêts de leur gîte et c
est bon c'est ça qui crée la disparition
des oiseaux les pauvres chasseurs mais
d'oka je veux te dire ils sont une
poignée et vieillissent très des jeunes
il y retourne pas à chasser un torrent
je crois que cela leur cellule est
vraiment un concours faut être patient
et ils boivent beaucoup il vise pas
toujours évident et va comment ils
semblent se termine un merveilleux
merveilleux nervis est ce qu'ils sont